Here let's calculate the average number of shoes owned by females: =average
(A2:A8). We get 33.14. Here let's calculate the average pairs of shoes owned by
males. Looks like on guy owns a lot of shoes. We get 18. Here we'll calculate
squared deviations for females. And in column D, square deviations for males.
In cell c2, we'll put equals a2 minus dollar sign a dollar sign 10. So we're
subtracting the mean. And then square it. This time let's just drag it down.
Now we have all our square deviations. We'll take the sum of squares and divide
by n minus 1, which is 6. There we have our variance. And if we take the square
root of the variance We get the sample standard deviation. Now I'll do the same
for males, and then we get that the standard deviation is 34.27. If you're very
comfortable calculating this step by step, you know exactly what to do and you
don't have to remember anything or review how to do it. Then feel free to
calculate the standard deviation using the function stdev. If we write equals
stdev, and then put the cells a2 to a8, then we get the same thing. And same
here. Equals stdev, We want the standard deviation of the pairs of shoes owned
by men. B2 colon B12. That's a good way to check your answers. But if you don't
know how to do this step by step, then I really recommend to continue
practicing to the point that it becomes second nature. because that'll help you
remember the process and understand what's going on in the calculation of the
standard deviation. Now, we have almost all the information we need to do the t
test.